so let's dive right in
vanilla ice the first rapper to make
Zack Morris look threatening was at the
top of his game in the late 80s early
90s so how do I couldn't help but try
and cash in on his 15 minutes of shame
by making him the star of his own motion
picture cool as ice so let's see how
this melting pit of ass begins ah ah
oh you are in trouble yeah I can tell
this is gonna be a very story driven
movie this man says whiteness plenty
about posted on the side of his head
take a lot of time for me to climb a
door for mine like a monkey on a pine
it's the latest dance move the Raggedy
Ann seizure turn the body up in my
opinion weight work make a warm at the
moon boy you gotta just love the
creative editing I get off the beach hey
I wonder who's gonna be in the next shot
Oh ice again what a shocker I haven't
been this surprised since I find out the
next person to be on the cover of
Oprah's magazine what's up bro
Oh special pants is that business talk
for kidnapped her so after that blast
from the ass our movie finally begins in
a haunted house look at his hair it
looks like a level from Super Mario
Brothers I'm watching your PG movie so
Hindman is passe get on their motorbikes
and ride off to try and find the plot ah
man we're in the desert
I better be careful else I'm gonna build
over there man there's real good spots
to rip off Top Gun
wow what a nice hole hey you okay
damn what the hell's wrong with you what
the hell is wrong with you nothing till
now
Oh would I hurt you yeah you hit pretty
good for it girl
yeah well coming from a big macho biker
like I'll take that as a compliment
Cuvier Church day I love you so while
they drive through the trees on loan
from the Mushroom Kingdom one of the
guys bikes breaks down and it has to be
repaired so while looking for a place to
get it fixed
they get a not so nice welcome
Bonzo who lavas raving rapscallions into
our neighborhood so they stopped by
brain-fuck Central where a silly old
lady on one of the crazy guys from One
Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest offers to
fix their bike that is after a rather
goofy misunderstanding you're like what
happened to you
you said you'd be here an hour ago and
you call this thing
time my god I wouldn't give you five
hundred for it
Oh may have a wisdom damn it get real
Rosco this bike is worth more than our
half if you ever do want somebody to
work on it why don't you give us a call
we're best around
y'all can fix teeth the spatula on my
head approves of this situation so the
gang sits around for a bit while okay
what is up with this place that old
couple lives here it's like a Flavor
Flav redesign pee-wee's Playhouse
well that's nice
it'd make you weird out food look like
door make okay Winky we in sandwich so
while ice does his ice G he noses the
girl from the horse earlier as she
coincidentally happens to live next door
mark Kathy we both know what's gonna
happen couples always break up when they
go away to different colleges that's
what you want I didn't say that Chubby's
a couple girls it'll be glad to hear I'm
sure there are hmm the white a meter is
certainly up there but there has to be
something else to make this scene even
whiter yeah yeah yeah there we go
what the hell is that so what's up how
you doing my god these ratings are high
I haven't seen a rapper this white says
funky T snowman continue to pull us away
I continue to blow us away wait a minute
you two know each other now but yeah
well which is a Kathy Kathy mm-hmm cat
V come on we're wasting this time
oh no you're not wasting my time I'm
just cool it you know
oh yeah cat words of wisdom drop that
zero and get with the heat yeah I got
that off the Disney Channel pull this
out all about forget him I already have
and so will the rest of the world in six
months is the movie just decide to fast
forward I mean I'm very grateful but I'm
also very confused
God somebody say hey it's like a
domestic version of the cleaning room
scene from any profits
quite finish thank you so yeah the real
movie comes back again and apparently
Kathy's family is very happy to see that
she's on TV or riding a horse this must
be a very boring neighborhood no she's
on Hill don't make Jill Jill Jill people
can be whatever they want to be as long
as they're willing to work and um that's
all I've been doing oh man she's meltin
aha
cuz it's me Chris meanwhile at Andy
Warhol's Fixit shop we find out that the
fixing of the bike might take a little
longer than they thought it's right here
right before your eyes don't you see it
that's his bike can you put it back
together with quickness when will that
be
maybe tomorrow tomorrow oh come on man
we got time we could be wasting but it's
okay it just gives a walking crossword
puzzle a ton more time to flirt with
Kent hey yo what's up man oh you must be
one of those imitations like people I've
heard about yeah I'm looking for cat I'm
sorry but Cathy's not here right now I
don't suppose you know where she is
I'm sorry I don't Tommy the Sugar Shack
effect like there's a club called Sugar
Shack I think most candy stores will be
embarrassing that name it was a very
pleasant meeting you ma'am
remember honey whenever you see someone
like that just run straight home and
watch shaft okay so they go to the Sugar
Shack when they see their musical
entertainment there's nothing to get too
excited about let it stop Jason
Wow
you must have to set the musical bar low
to make Vanilla Ice look good but max
headache comes in to put his stamp on
the situation on this town Kevin you
wanna dance
whoa
it's Lynch ice yep yep oh dear let's get
the white and meter out again drop it oh
yeah I'm gonna drop funky lyrics 31 cuz
you're a nerd I'm 1st to 3rd it's absurd
to think that you heard the sweet
candy-coated Jesus Wonder Bread eaten by
a conservative congressman in the middle
of a snowstorm hits in fists fly come on
uh thank you but net all day Joe's dance
steps I think they call that the
two-year-old west of beam thank you baby
better swing care to be lame with me
don't look back whack go take a nap get
off the crack jack so is this their job
just hijacking parties and making them
even creamier than they need to be
I'm the People's Choice boo-hoo-hoo
I find you charming now for no reason
but Lord preppin douche is not the least
bit pleased with this situation I'm
willing to forgive you for this hey I
said I'm willing to forgive you for this
Hey
forgot I'm glad I had this talk you know
something Nick you really are a dick get
in the car Kathy I said get in the car
Kathy hey I'm talking to you
don't make me pout so Kathy decides to
walk home but sees a couple of bad men
who are apparently tracking her not so
subtly gee I wonder if that car that's
only three feet away is following me
Oh
that I don't know but it was cool as ice
so I structure backhaul matter saving
her from the very slow-moving vehicle so
what's up with tomorrow I don't know man
what's the what's up with tomorrow don't
mock me I'm gonna last forever what are
we doing
I'm waiting so waste returns back to the
funky house where Kathy's boyfriend
seems to be causing trouble a little bed
and practice on your bike not mine
Sardi's who's RD my homeboy if this
scene was any more white it'd be
transparent homeboy this
so the next morning ice actually breaks
into Kathy's home and I'm not kidding
here actually wakes her up with ice good
lord I hate to see dick buck hisses
wake-up call seeing me now hmm you know
I'm not for the object ation of women
but the only thing that can possibly
save this movie is an Uzi I mean at
least we could go for just flat-out
smart and entertain some happy mom says
I'm gonna get out of here for you so I
said Kathy drive together to the most
romantic spot they can think of a
construction site hi
so how long have you lived here Oh fine
you like my shorts I got them from the
Hamburglar what's it like what do you
think what's it like you know having
parents and all that stuff brother all
that stuff nice Oh
okay we only got ambushed by Calvin
Klein
why is it I think the feeling this is
what black people think white people do
all day and we're guys talking to you I
don't think there's anything wrong with
working hard
imagine this okay we're back to
frolicking so it's important to you now
we're back to talk can you break a
scenario this is one of those choose
your own adventure books just pick a
crappy scene this day with it
you're a true to yourself then you ain't
shooting nobody if you like to someone
else you ain't living is these then of
ice sites what is up with this movie
it's like the whole film is one long
commercial but they forgot what the
product was so they return the Caucasian
Meadows where ice tries to say good
night to Kathie no difference between
you and anybody oh yeah oh yeah
but the father from family ties it's not
amused get out of here get out leave my
daughter alone but Dad you understand
get inside I'll handle this
it's because I'm black isn't it I'll see
you tomorrow cat I don't want you near
her tomorrow or any other day isn't that
up to her no it's all to me genetically
we just can't have any more whiteness
and we had anymore we just vanished so
to be fair the father thinks ice is
connected to the two guys who try to run
Cathy over the other night and just who
are those two guys that was a policeman
practically a rookie that partner guy
named Walsh thought I was pretty square
oh come on don't try to have a story now
you're like an hour I guess I was that I
was also honest and Walsh wasn't two
other cops were convicted with Walsh
love love life fuck up in the head
these students want revenge and they're
willing to hurt his family for recycled
retarded rejected Maxine hey yo what's
up I was just chillin in the hood and I
thought you might want to go for ride
the hood the hood whoa boy the hood of
your car you know sometimes I think I
know you but then how can you know
somebody that you just met right just
you or your old man talkin me you don't
know me you don't know me at all
there's only one thing that'll make me
feel better and that's posed okay is
this just an editor's test project take
a bunch of random shots and somehow make
a movie out of it Johnny I thought maybe
we could go for a ride
so I could giving Kathy's brother a
friendly ride on his bike he sneaks into
her room to give back the love ring that
she gave
by the way is it me boys the music
starting to sound like Inspector Gadget
unfortunately those two villains
mentioned before breaking to their home
and look for some family members I'm
gonna get you Wow he's having all
fighting with himself okay that didn't
happen but when they've been such a dark
turn
no they just decide to kidnap him
because any bad movie where the kid
isn't the star has to have him be
kidnapped I am making this tape to tell
you what a very good to my new friends
and of course they think ice is one of
the guys who kidnapped him and it
doesn't help that jock macaque here
confirms the misunderstanding as well
I just don't tell me I good yeah the guy
who taught me at the Sugar Shack no no
don't come back well I tried you know I
think these guys just hang out with ie
so that they look less lame by
comparison I need to talk to you you
need a psychiatrist you are so blind
not black you're blind up black your
blood I know what you're talking about
if you change your mind in the next 24
hours I will come home do it you have to
do and everything will be okay well this
is the worst rap tape I've ever heard
kids got no rhyme no rhythm you've got
no talent so detective ice puts together
that the kid is being held at where else
the construction site good god doesn't
any actual construction go on there
what's the lead Martian life is he your
lead Martian is he your leader
you are ours well can you just cut my
head off already
your acting's really bad and they are
gone
when this whole thing is said and done
you don't want to go alright get myself
a joint that is quite a coincidence
that's why I've been saying I do after
this movie to the Vanilla Ice and the
popsicles come in to save the day this
looks like a job for a chewed up black
condom and so they return the son home
get the bad guys in jail and of course
ice has a chance to make amends with
Candy's father and yes he does the whole
thing while looking like the top of a
baby bottle thanks doesn't really matter
no I'm out of here
oh I thought we were out of here
then let's G oh wait I'm come to add the
ultimate cliche to the movie you know
what you're doing I hope not
well I hope you like being a biker chick
cuz you're not gonna see me or my car
again I forgot something go please
don't do it
the white a meter is already at its
maximum limit I am no idea how much more
whiteness this movie can see
- why why so he goes back to his
nightclub though we're not really sure
why he left to begin with where he's
quite literally wrapping it up godo mass
go dumbass go your dumb ass go dumbass
go this more with that can look at that
amazing technicolor stop coat it looks
like you lost at a game of paintball um
okay that's a little questionable but I
guess it wasn't too bad Wow damn that's
like five pages of the Kama Sutra in the
house and the house is packed did they
just spit the in credit at us oh well
who cares it's over thank God it's over
so that was cool it and it is bad as
shit I mean do we even have to explain
why this movie is bad the plan is just
an excuse to make Vanilla Ice look good
and because the plot fails so horribly
so does the task of making a look going
he's not that great an actor he's not
that great a rapper and what the hell if
someone could just run a lawnmower
through his hair already how well who
cares the movies over and thank God if I
had to take anymore whiteness I don't
know what the hell would a half drop
that zero and get with the heat oh no
mr. right mr. white
face the music 10 I'm right behind with
a copy of mine and a funky bond it
doesn't take a lot of time for me to fly